Israeli forces have stormed the Al-Aqsa
mosque in occupied East Jerusalem and
fired replicated bullets and stun
grenades of Palestinians during Ramadan
prayers their accusing worshipers of
barricading themselves after exceeding
the agreed timings videos show women and
children crying for help as Israeli
forces beat worshipers with batons that
resulted in at least seven Palestinians
being injured
the Palestinian prisoners Affairs
commission says 400 people have been
arrested
after the incursions Israel says that at
least 11 Rockets have been fired from
Gaza into Southern Israel in the early
hours of Wednesday a number of them have
been intercepted according to a
statement let's speak to human al-said
who joins us live on the phone from Gaza
what more can you tell us about these
rocket attacks yumna
uh tourmaline until now uh at least 11
rockets in total they were fired at
different times in the early hours of
Wednesday uh they all fell in empty
areas While others were intercepted at
least one rocket was said to have hit a
factory instead Road causing partial
damage to the building of the factory uh
the deputy head of the political Bureau
of Hamas
he said in a statement that the Israeli
aggression against the blessed and
Oxford mosque today and what it
committed against the worshipers and
those in Retreat is a major crime to
which our people and their resistance
will respond with through uh with full
force he also added that a cold had been
made everywhere to the Palestinian
people in different areas of the
occupied lands in his words and the West
Bank to face the tenuous crime so that
everyone
knows that hardening sensitive will be
punished and a big price will be paid
the other hand the Secretary General of
the Islamic Jihad movement is also
confirmed that what is happening in
Alaska mosque constitutes a serious
threat to the Muslim sanctities and in a
statement he issued a dole today
Wednesday he said that the Palestinian
people must be present for this
inevitable confrontation in the coming
days so far Moline there is no response
by the Israeli Army on the launching of
the Rockets we're still waiting to see
how the situation will develop in the
coming hours okay thank you for that
update you know outside speaking just
down on the phone from Gaza let's turn
to our correspondent Natasha ganim who
has the latest from occupy Jerusalem
this is not a surprise yesterday on
social media I saw the bombastic
rhetoric circulating on social media
with calls for Palestinians to come to
Al-Aqsa mosque in anticipation of uh the
Passover holiday on Wednesday morning in
which Jews will be expected from seven
o'clock in the morning until 11 30 to
visit the compound as part of non-muslim
visiting hours so this these type of
clashes again were expected based on
what I was seeing on social media the
police are saying that dozens of people
barricaded themselves inside el-aqsa
mosque late Tuesday night into Wednesday
morning they say the police that the the
people had a stockpile of stone sticks
and fireworks the police say that they
attempted to coax the people to come
outside of the mosque there was a
agreement with the compound authorities
that no one would be spending the night
police say when they could not coax the
people to come out peacefully that is
when they entered the mosque and began
firing stun guns and forcibly removing
people there have been some injuries and
there have been arrests